[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host rachel
cruz ramsey personality number one new
york times best-selling author multiple
times and my daughter is my co-host
today we'll be answering your questions
about your life and your money open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five the advice is free and
some say it's worth every penny
triple eight eight two five five two two
five arnel is gonna start us off in
california hey arnel what's up in your
world
hello it's a pleasure speaking with you
youtube shed some light on my life i'm
very excited about it
basically paying off our mortgage that's
where we are and building wealth nice
so my question is we are about ready to
sell
a piece of real estate which we've owned
for 30 something years
and it will go for 1.5 million
approximately we've just got our first
offer
and we split that with my brother-in-law
since we co-own it
with that money let's just say 700 000
we're gonna pay off
another rental property and our primary
residence and then we'll have about
five hundred thousand dollars left i
hate it when those are
i know
we are 65 and 68 so we're in that stage
of our life and we're not quite sure
what to do with that money
what do you suggest
so that means you're at baby step seven
you're millionaires
and you've done it you're good shape
you've you're completely debt free and
you got an extra half million dollars
that you just have to figure out what to
do well you address it to dave's cabo
fund
and you send it no i'm kidding okay
why are the money to the cayman i
started writing that down
i'm so proud of you guys well done
arnelle
do you feel like do you feel
accomplished because you should
i i do i came from nothing you know
inner city projects of new york and
we've really done well so i'm very
excited what were your careers
currently we both own our own business
my husband and i are both prosthetists
so we make artificial limbs for amputees
wow and
then i have been a special ed teacher
i've been a homeschooling mom
a prosthetist and now i own my own
gluten-free organic baking mix company
which i am about to sell wow
yeah nothing's stopping you that's
amazing
all right well there's only three things
you can do with money that's give it
enjoy it
and invest it so that you can give it
and enjoy it
and so we always recommend with money
that's laying around
that you are intentional with it that
you give it a give it an uh an
assignment
uh before it gets there
because if it gets there and you don't
give it an assignment it can slip away
and so you say we're going to enjoy
by going on a trip or buying some item
or some lifestyle decision
some of this money and it's x number of
dollars and we're going to buy this
thingy with it or whatever it is you
write it down and we're going to uh
we're going to be generous with it we're
going to find some people that uh need
some help uh like where you came from
and you say we're going to help them get
started we're going to help them with
their life whoever that is and that's
outrageous generosity and
then we're going to uh obviously invest
some of it uh and you can buy a piece of
paid for real estate which is what i do
or and or you could
invest in good mutual funds which is
what i do
but
what a great story no it's amazing
arnold do you guys have kids
yes we have two daughters
and grandkids maybe two
okay any grandkids not yet not yet okay
no grandkids yet but for your two
daughters yep that's wonderful well i
mean i mean i feel like that this is
always just oh go ahead
i have a question about
index annuities
somebody was telling me that one called
like american national that's like a
fixed index
flexible premium that has this range but
you can never lose the money if the
market crashes any thoughts about that
yeah there's uh yeah i wouldn't do fixed
annuities but a variable annuity might
be a play and it does give you a
protection of principle and it'll even
give you a floor on a minimum it will
make however their fees are higher and
so
you're going to pay more fees there than
if you buy a mutual fund and basically
they're going to require in most cases
that you leave the money in there long
for a long period of time or otherwise
you're going to have surrender charges
and if you have the surrender charges
then um
uh uh you know if you had left it alone
five years in a mutual fund it wouldn't
have gone down anyway
on average that's why they're able to
make that guarantee so
uh i'm 60 i don't have any variable
annuities but i'm not worried about the
stock market i'm not worried that i'm
going to lose money i'm going to ride
out any downturns from there is there
ever a time frame to do
a variable annuity this would be it if
you were going to do it uh it's the only
time only after your home is paid for
and all your other retirement stuff's
maxed out
and it grows tax deferred it sits in
there and grows
but again you don't really have good
access to it and the guarantee that it
makes
you know if you look at the historical
data on what the stock market actually
does actually does
you don't really need that guarantee if
you're going to leave alone five years
or seven years right use that right so
you're gonna get you're gonna make a
floor of five percent or more
if you didn't it'd be the first time in
the history of the market you're gonna
get your you're gonna at least make your
principal but if you want to sleep a
little bit better and you don't you know
you want that guarantee i'm not mad
about it i i'm okay if people buy these
i don't want you buying them
for your iras and stuff like that
because that stuff's already
got stuff got you know it's already
built in
and so um we don't need to do principal
protection on that stuff but if you want
to with this some of this money that's
fine but i think the thing i want you to
leave with her now is
you should do all three things with the
money
i don't care what the amounts are but
you need to spend some on you
and sometimes people like you don't do
that enough
you've done a great job we hear that a
lot especially people that have
sacrificed and have worked
decades literally and i mean she's in
southern california right even true i
mean
it's so her i mean if her house is paid
for there you know it's been a long time
that you know they've put money towards
you've been diligent and then to be able
to look up and actually have the freedom
to spend it's like it's a muscle you
have to learn to grow if you haven't
already yeah and sometimes the
generosity muscle outrageous generosity
you know sometimes people think
generosity is five bucks no not not when
you're sitting on that kind of money
that's not generosity that's cheap
so no i mean you need to find about
about five or six single arms and bomb a
car
you know or something like that
that kind of thing you need to have some
fun with the generosity piece of this
and get all down in somebody's business
and really help them
and um
you know we've all had people help us
over the years in different ways
sometimes it was encouragement sometimes
it was an actual dollar amount
uh but that's that's why you do this and
so make sure you're doing all three
things with this yeah but you've done
such a good job so proud of you this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today she is the author of the
new bestseller know yourself know your
money new york times bestseller discover
why you handle money the way you do and
what to do about it the know yourself
money assessment
is uh twenty dollars for individuals
thirty dollars for couples great for
couples that want to get on the same
page you get your money profile and
beliefs your money classrooms how you
grew up your money tendencies and fears
and motivations and attitudes and
actions it all prints out and you will
look at your spouse and go oh that's why
you do that
so be sure and check all that out no
parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being unprepared
for an emergency
well we've got your back with our
digital self-study courses for teenagers
you can rest assured that your teen will
know the right way to handle money no
matter what curveball's life can throw
them best part is no instructors needed
if your teen has a tablet or a computer
they're all set parents text self-study
to thirty three seven eight nine
self-study to three three
seven eight nine and you can learn more
about the different courses we have for
middle school and for high school you'll
see rachel cruz featured on most all of
those jimmy is with us jimmy is in st
louis hi jimmy welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave hey rachel thanks for taking my
call sure
what's up i am
uh
basically just laid out there i'm 27
years old um i have no debt other than a
mortgage
i bought this house back in march and i
have about 49 000 left on it wow
i have a home repair that set me sent me
back from step six to step three
um
i'm currently sitting on about thirty
thousand individual stocks outside of
401k
and uh i'm just kind of i'm trying to
figure out what to do with it do i
replenish my emergency fund and reinvest
the rest of it
uh just pour the rest of it back into my
mortgage do i reinvest all of the
uh these stocks with mutual funds um
i i'm just wanting to get your take on
it
yeah well our general rule of thumb is
always not to own individual stock
because majority of your of your net
worth and so i mean we always say you
know
if all your eggs are in one basket right
i mean just the idea of diversification
is so much better when it comes to
investing so like you said mutual funds
is the best way to go in that case so if
i were you i would yes cash out those
individual stocks replenish baby step
three and then go right back down to the
baby steps which would mean a lot of
that probably will be in baby step six
for you especially if you've maxed out
baby step four already all of your
retirement what's this house worth
uh
i bought it at about 70 000 it ended up
uh having to have a few repairs uh
the appraisal came in at like 80. um
so good for you
okay so what do you make
i make
us
about 58 after taxes okay so what is the
uh how much does it take to replenish
the emergency fund
um
probably another eight thousand i i've
been trying so i would put eight
thousand and that and twenty two
thousand on the house
okay and then you're gonna be done with
your house in under three years exactly
what rachel said
okay yeah that just walking right down
the baby steps you replenish that
emergency fund and then just lean in on
that house dude you're so close and as
young as you are you're in great shape
you have done a fabulous job touchdown
baby good job
jeremy's with us in oklahoma city hi
jeremy welcome to the ramsay show
hey david rachel how are you great how
can we help
yeah i'm a second lieutenant in the air
force uh and i'll be promoting to first
lieutenant here in september
my wife and i have been loosely
following the baby steps
we just moved from
pensacola florida to oklahoma so we had
some moving expenses we had to save up a
little bit more than a thousand dollars
to start with
um in the apartment we got here in
oklahoma it's kind of inadequate and we
were ready for a house so we sort of
jumped the gun a bit and bought a house
when we still had about 5 500 left to
pay on my truck but that's our only debt
so i guess my question is now that we
have a house and more can go wrong would
you suggest throwing everything
available at the truck to go ahead and
get it paid off or increasing the
initial emergency fund before we uh
pay off that truckload
jeremy i'm just curious what what about
the situation for you guys were you guys
in a house in florida and then you moved
to an apartment and you just kind of got
restless i'm just curious kind of the
the why behind that decision to jump the
gun you guys were just kind of
discontent
sure thing uh so we just got married in
december we were in an apartment in
florida uh which really we actually
really liked and then the apartment we
got that was available when we got to
oklahoma uh you know air force moves us
when they decide to move us
um the only thing we could find was was
not the best
um this is an example our apartment
smelled like wheat all the time neither
of us smoke it was just seeping in from
the walls of our neighbors basically
and then there were some some issues
where we were having
trouble getting maintenance done in the
apartment because the maintenance guy
lives next door and he was high all the
time
[Laughter]
and as part of part of our military pay
we do get a housing allowance and we
were able to find a we were able to find
a house that was within that housing
allowance yeah we're in a 30-year fixed
va loan um
and as i said i'm going to promote here
in september uh so my my take-home pay
yeah after taxes will increase by about
a thousand dollars a month and how much
will that how much will that be a year
um
so right now before the before the
promotion it's about 50 000 a year after
tax
uh so it'll be up to about
60 000 a year
after tax and that's just my income my
wife als another reason we decided to
jump the guns my wife just got a job on
base right now she's making 12.33 an
hour but it fluctuates from 20 to 40
hours a week so we didn't
factor that into a budget my my income
pays for all of our expenses
okay
okay so the rule of thumb when it comes
to buying a house the reason why we
always say to wait is because probably
what you're learning pretty quickly is
that owning a home is expensive right
it's not just the purchase of the home
it's everything else that kind of goes
into play but whether you're a homeowner
or not
still focusing on the debt and getting
that truck paid off as soon as possible
is going to be your main focus so i
would not up the emergency funds keep it
at a thousand and if something comes up
and you have to pause paying off the
truck to save up to fix something in the
house then that's what you have to do
but besides that
still attacking that 5 500 and then
building up that emergency fund so so
again the reason
for everyone listening is that when you
still have debt and you don't have a lot
of savings and you buy a home and
something does break it just
makes the whole situation stressful it's
more of a curse
than a blessing of what a house should
be it just doesn't bring that peace so
for you guys i would just say jeremy to
make that be extra motivation to be like
all right we're gonna get this truck
paid off fast we're gonna get some cash
in the bank to save up more
so that we're not kind of ugh because
you you feel it you said we're jumping
we jumped the gun a little so you're
feeling a little bit of that stress i
know
so thank you for your service
um i think rachel's right but listen
listen dude here's the thing
okay
you're screwing around with this stuff
you're running around making up your own
rules and in your head what you did was
smart and it wasn't smart
you did it out of order yes you jumped
the gun but you're not concerned about
jumping the gun and you should be
you screwed up and so don't screw up
again
decide you're gonna work these baby
steps
exactly and with military-like
discipline
one thousand dollars is baby step one
beans and rice rice and beans i don't
want to see your butt in a restaurant
until you get this truck paid off unless
you're working there's your extra job
and the fact that you're making more
money is not an excuse to be stupid and
it's not an excuse to get things out of
order so you gotta tighten up man
and uh it's time to do that now you can
do that or you cannot do that you're a
grown guy you get to decide what you're
going to do but you called here and
asked us what to do and so what you're
going to get is a proven plan that
millions of people have done you don't
need to fix this it's not broken
you need to just execute on it
exactly
and with discipline and so the fact you
know all the people most the people
working baby steps one through three
have a house and they all start with
baby step one being a thousand dollars
yeah
but what you're feeling in your gut is
the fear of something breaking in that
house into rachel's point that's exactly
why you shouldn't bought the stupid
house because you're broke and when
broke people buy houses stuff in their
house breaks that's how this works
that's why they call them mortgage
brokers and real estate brokers it gets
you broker and broker
and it's not a blessing so you know you
need to roll up your sleeves and tear
your tear into this thing man tear into
it and get that car gone get that
emergency fund built by christmas get it
done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
right here in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage james
and megan are with us hey guys how are
you hey we're good how are you better
than we deserve welcome and all the way
from where do you live
charlotte north carolina to do a
debt-free screen
how much did you pay off
249
756 dollars and 57 cents ding ding ding
way to go
how long did this take
three years three months and 20 days wow
that's a lot in a fast yeah what's your
household income during that time the
range um it ranged it started at about
120 and um
we're on track to probably clear a
little over 165 000 now excellent way to
go what do y'all do for a living i'm a
project manager
and a real estate and a real estate
agent on the side um i'm a
deployment engineer
okay excellent software so what kind of
debt was the 250 000
everything uh we had medical bills we
had credit cards car
student loans was most of it my fault
okay wow how long you all been married
uh almost five years almost in october
so not long after marriage you look up
and go oh my god there's a lot of dad we
gotta do what happened tell us the story
our daughter was born
that's a wake-up call
yeah no pun intended
some of us were dragging our feet a
little more than others
um but um i came home one day and she
said i paid off the medical debt from
our daughter and i said how did you do
that we didn't we didn't have that money
and she said uh that credit card that
the uh the bank gave me um that's
connected to the house equity um i paid
it with that and i said you did what
this
medical debt had no interest and you
just put it on something that's got
interest
and i ran into the office grabbed the
paper shredder down the middle of the
floor and we had a shred party right
there
whoa
a debit card got shredded in the process
too
anything that was plastic yeah the whole
driver's license everything yeah
oh my gosh i was yeah i was done
okay oh man sounds like a big fight oh
yeah there was there was more than
a water bill got paid on it yeah yeah
for you it was just hey i'm gonna try to
help that's right the process you said
you didn't know it was a little bit of
an ignorance absolutely yeah okay so the
meltdown and the the famous shred night
and then what happens
and then um we my dad actually had
purchased um financial piece for me
years ago and it was on the shelf so
that came out and we started the journey
on our own oh wow then we um we found a
church group that was doing one and we
went and and did it with the church
group and wow we became coordinators and
started teaching our own classes to kind
of keep ourselves accountable that'll do
it and um we're still doing classes
today nothing like teaching something to
make sure you learn it oh yeah yeah
wow way to go you guys yeah yep
we're doing three and we're on to uh
four five and six wow amazing so well
done yeah how does it feel great it's
like a
giant weight lifted off my shoulders i
when i graduated college with all that
debt i honestly thought i would never
i was i was hesitant to get married have
kids
because i saw this massive amount of
debt and i was like i don't want to put
this on anybody else and i'll never pay
this off
and then when i met her i was like well
i can't let her
go and so i got married and i figured
we're going to figure out how to get
through this and then so it was like 200
grand in student loan debt oh yeah yeah
he went private school cross country oh
yeah just a whole enchilada baby
megan actually called your show i did oh
what did i say
after you were nice you were
surprising on some of the stuff you said
but um
we got a call from i didn't warn her
about my student debt and they called
her because i was delinquent on a lot of
it and they said um we're willing to
settle
a hundred and twenty thousand of it for
eight thousand dollars
and yeah on student loans yeah did they
do it they did it
yeah and but what they did is they took
the they took the principal balance and
they took 10 of the principal balance
and settled for the 10 of the principal
balance wow and we did it we got it all
in writing she called you you told her
yeah do this deal before they changed
her mind yeah um she said we didn't have
a credit card at the time we didn't have
a grand at the time we didn't have eight
grand at a time so she said you know
should we get a credit card to do this
and you explained like yes today you
have a hundred you know 120 thousand
dollars on debt tomorrow you have eight
grand and an irs
issue
right um and
it's totally worth it i mean i can't i
can't tell anybody enough if you're
hesitant about this or you think you're
doing dave-ish or any of this stuff
you know
stop stop doing all that just go all in
and submit yourself to the process
yeah
do it
so you guys were newly parents though
new parents and you kind of started this
we are our two oldest um
are from a previous marriage okay okay
i'm sorry i'm sorry yeah but you had had
your daughter though which was kind of
the wake up call yes so
so what was the hardest part cause i'm
like i know
it's it's hard right when you when you
have a new baby and you're trying to
figure out life it's expensive all of it
so what would be what would you say to
people that had their first baby and
they're realizing wow we got to get our
money in order yeah um i mean we we
really don't we we would go on family a
family vacation a year and we usually
went with like a parent and they kind of
helped us along the way um we would
budget to save for what we needed to
save
everything but we we really we didn't
really go out to eat we we just ate in
and we had beans and rice some nights
with the kids and yeah um like i mean
our our children um you know they they
would only get to play like one
extracurricular activity a year like we
couldn't do everything so they've
sacrificed you know right there with us
but
it's totally been worth the sacrifice i
mean it sucks seeing your friends and
other family members do all these
extravagant wonderful things but now
like we can go do those things
um
they're in debt and you're not right
that's right you don't have to when we
come home from vacation we don't have to
keep it with us yeah it doesn't follow
you home that's right it's awesome i
mean
guys you know the key that i tell people
is
contentment teamwork and focus
that's good and uh
if you can just do those things then you
can get through it i know it seems like
a lot but you can i promise you can get
through it yeah and it's kind of a it's
a it's a contentment that goes
hey it's two years three years you can
do anything hold your breath for three
years and i went to college for three
years so i could do this for three years
why not clean up college
wow amazing guys you guys are so i'm so
proud of you great well done thank you
who were your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you
my dad was a big one yeah yeah
got the fpu kid off the shelf and blew
the dust off of it our children were big
cheerleaders um because they knew at the
end of it
you know they
they get their own room and and we're
gonna you know work on getting that for
them and
um
going on vacations and disney we've
promised disney at some point we're
gonna do that we got a budget for that
okay very good so fun well we got a copy
of the legacy journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure onto
being baby steps millionaires before you
know it you guys are right on track well
done well done well done you make great
money you got no payments you got
control teamwork contentment focus game
on man game on copy the total money
makeover too for you to give away to
somebody i'm sure you know that way a
lot thank you thank you we'll let one of
them be free from you thank you thank
you very much well done james and megan
from charlotte north carolina 250
000 dollars paid off in three years and
three months making 120 to 165
count it down let's hear a debt-free
screen before we do this so i want to
thank you and your team personally as
well
thank you all right three two one
[Applause]
rachel somebody out there is looking on
their bookshelf and they see a dusty
financial piece university kit
and you need to pull it off right now
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
number one best-selling author new york
times best-selling author of the latest
book
know yourself know your money discover
why you handle money the way you do and
what to do about it dan is in modesto
california hi dan welcome to the ramsey
show
thanks dave how you doing better than i
deserve how can i help
so i'm just having a little bit of
a
qualm right now with
trying to decide where to go okay
i am a plumber right now as service
plumber i work on commission
because i've found that really the
best places to work around here and make
decent money is uh to be on commission
based now that means a hundred percent
of my income is commission okay i have
no base salary so my my
income varies very wildly
what's your worst money
my worst month was about uh 3 000 take
home what will it be in the next year
what will be your worst month in the
next year
um probably about 2 000 to 2500. why why
would you have a worse month than your
worst month ever so far and you've been
doing it a while
it should be bad well it
this is true okay so what's been your
best month
my best month has been uh eight thousand
take home
okay so three to eight thousand is your
range that we're working with right and
so that's wildly okay how much is your
rent 15.50 a month okay
and your question is what
so i've been trying to work extra to try
to
to make sure that my worst months stay
as
minimal as possible meaning you know i i
don't have those bad months
uh the only problem with that is
i the way we do it is i work on call so
i would be on call over overnight or and
then on the weekends but if the calls
don't come in i don't really i don't get
paid anything for just being on call
right so i'm wondering should i continue
to work these extra shifts and you know
hope that the calls come in or should i
maybe look somewhere else where i would
be making much less per call because i
average you know if i'm actually working
on the weekends i average about 45
dollars an hour to 65 somewhere in there
depending on the job or should i take a
job making way less an hour
but it's guaranteed
dan where are you like when it comes to
debt savings like what you're just your
financial picture what does that look
like
yeah so we've got about 54 000 total
debt
um we're renting right now uh so we
don't have the mortgage and um we have
we have a thousand our
thousand for baby step one in the
savings and then i've got a thousand in
the checking right now that i keep there
because i don't know what my next
paycheck is going to be so i want to
keep that just in case utilities are a
little high or something like that yeah
yeah
well when it comes to
understanding just the budgeting process
with a commission based um
i don't say salary because it's not
salary your own commission um
is is mapping out priorities
and so those first four things being
that rent
your utilities transportation and food
and so like these are the things that
absolutely have to be paid every single
month like we have to have money for
these things to survive
and then everything else under that i
would list in priority uh this is the
next this is the next thing we need next
next night all the way down
and the goal would be to get to a place
because there is such a swing for you
that on that you can live off of that
budget
that of okay if everything if we could
do everything we needed to right we
could live off this budget
and then on the months that we make more
than that we put we put it away and in a
different you know it could be in your
checking account it would i don't care
what it is
for the down months you can pull from
that it's kind of that slush funds that
you're keeping month to month and people
that are on commission
there's a level of that that you need um
to be able to for that to be your safety
net so i would do that
and then
as regard to your question on which job
uh you should take if you do do the
hourly or get a
lesser paying you know hourly position
somewhere else um i would map out i mean
on average how much are you making when
you're working overtime with that
plumbing company where you're making
more
and just see over maybe a three month
period
clocking exactly how much you're making
extra and then run the numbers that if
you're in a lower paying job how many
hours would you be working to make that
type and kind of just kind of like your
cost analysis yeah that's what i would
do here's what i'm hearing you didn't
grow up in a commission-based or
self-employed family
you grew up in a family that was
salaried
and so this is scaring your mom and dad
and it's scaring you because no because
you don't know how to emotionally
process these swings much less to how to
handle the math the math rachel just
told you how to do it with
prioritization
um and so
the way to back off and look at it is
this
everyone
is on straight commission
if you're on salary and you don't go to
work they quit paying you
they fire your butt right you know and
so you know everybody ultimately is on
straight commission and so the way
you've got to look at it is overall so
what i would do i heard a couple of
concerns one is i heard the
unpredictability's driving you nuts you
can't tell how much of the overtime and
how much of the on call to take and how
much not to take and you feel desperate
because of the volatility to take all of
it and it's keeping you working all the
time only you don't work all the time
because on call sometimes you're just
sitting there and you don't get the 45
bucks an hour uh and so what i would do
is say all right i'm going to make a
couple of assumptions in my business
model here
assumption is number one is i don't want
to work all the time
okay so how much do i want to work
and so you would take some overtime some
on-call shifts but not as many as you're
taking now are not as many as you're
taking when you get good and scared okay
and just say over the scope of a year i
want to work this many hours
okay now you're you're working 40 plus
these on calls right
correct okay and so if you're on call
you know you're you're
on call as much as 80 right
right so i would back that down and say
all right i got a wife a kid i got i got
a life and so i'm gonna work some on
call plus my 40 and so i'm going to work
50 or i'm going to work 60 for the next
three years
and i'm just going to dial it up and
back until i get to that each you know
i'm going to take the premium extra 20
hours of on-call but not the not the
40-hour of on-call you don't have to do
that today if i'm going to do that as my
assumption what's my income probably
going to be and you can estimate that
very close you've got a lot of details
based on what you told me
and that is your household income or
that's your income for this career
and uh it sounds to me like that that's
about a 70 or an 80 000 a year job
you have the ability to make 120 but
you're working an unreasonable number of
hours to get there so you're probably in
an 80 000 with some
ot some on call is that a fair guess
yes yeah so no you don't take a 40 000
year job when you're making 80
to get quote unquote stability because
what i just outlined really was
stability dan
that's a very predictable environment
that i just outlined and you can go do
that
so um
that's what i would do man i think but i
think you got to lay it out like that
and then you say all right what's the
minimum we've got to have every month to
eat and what rachel said you lay out
your priorities we call it the four
walls food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities before you
do anything else you lay that down
exactly in that order and then
everything else is listed
on a to-do list based on priority number
one is where all the money goes until
extra money past the four walls
until it's done then number two when
number two buckets full spills over to
number three when number three is full
spills over number four and that's how
you're going to work off your debt is
doing that now having done all of that
you may choose to crank it back up to 80
hours for a period of time as gazelle
intensity to attack that debt but at
that point you're doing it not out of
desperation due to the ins the emotional
insecurity of the variable income or the
unpredictability of it you're doing it
because we're attacking debt with a
system then
that's it i mean it's that's exactly it
the feeling which is very real
of holding your breath every month
thinking oh god we're gonna be able to
pay the bills we're gonna do it once you
have that plan in place and you're in
that formula that settles down
there you go
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to james charles
our producer kelly daniel our associate
producer and phone screener i'm dave
ramsey your host and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com thanks for listening
[Music]
four
three
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about life i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney we are ramsay personalities and
we each host shows on the ramsey
network and so we are here with you this
hour to take your calls triple eight
eight two five
five two two five it is a free call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john delaney will
take calls on your mental emotional
health relationships we'll talk about
ugly work stuff because that's what i
talk about uh and we'll take your career
questions your work questions hey ken
i'm on the ladder i want to get up the
ladder i want to get promoted i need to
get started in something else whatever
it is and of course we're going to take
your money questions john and i love to
be together doc always good to be on the
big show with you too man it's good to
see you i haven't seen you for yeah
about 12 hours i know we're fresh off a
wonderful time uh in dallas texas with
entre leadership summit it's always fun
too to be in a room
2500 liters that was fun fired up to get
better and entree throws a party yes
they do so so much fun triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number let's get it started with crystal
in las vegas nevada crystal how can we
help
hi thanks for having me on
well one of the issues i have is that
i've been at a company for like two
years and i'm not really getting
promoted in my career and i want to move
to another city to get a better job but
my boyfriend doesn't want to move and we
want to get married
now if i stay in las vegas i can't work
anywhere else because as a journalist we
have these things called non-compete
so it's either i stay here and get out
of journalism or i move and kind of
break up with him yeah well let's talk
about you for a second well let's forget
about him i'm not real thrilled with him
but we'll get to him in a moment john i
might have doc weigh in on this from a
relationship standpoint that's his area
but i do want to get
really clear on what your dream is in
this other city and why you want to go
there i want you to tell yourself not
just us why do you want to move forget
him
why do you want to move why is that
important
because i work a really tough schedule i
work like midnight to 8 a.m wednesday
through sunday and i fall asleep in
church and i don't really have much of
an outside life out of work
so i want to find something with a
better schedule
and that i can kind of move up the
ladder with go why why'd you get into
journalism
because i feel like everyone needs to
have their story told and i wanted to be
a representative for people of color in
different communities and to make sure
that everyone's accountable why
go one level deeper i love that answer
tell me why that's important to you
because when i was growing up in new
orleans and hurricane katrina happened i
felt as a person of color i was
personally ignored and no one was paying
attention to me and that inspired me to
perceive this career in journalism in
which i tell the story of people who are
at the bottom and who are being ignored
in society john
that's a why hey that's a why that one's
wired into your soul that's from your
story
so here's the deal the reason i just
walk you through that
is because you need to have that front
and center right now john's gonna walk
you through the relational piece uh but
i wanted you to hear you share why it's
so important that this this isn't a move
just for a job
this isn't a move
to make your boyfriend uncomfortable
this isn't about you and selfishness
this is about your purpose this is about
your why you need to make the move john
i think she makes the move whether he
comes or not and if they're talking
marriage and he's not willing to make a
move because of that why
i got some real problems john help me
out i'm the same so crystal walk us
through
i'm going to call him a knucklehead and
that's a that's a that's that's my
neutral right that's pretty gentle it's
right down the road in the middle of the
road for me tell me about this
knucklehead what what what what a part
about
your life mission is he not resonating
with
well i mean he's been here for a long
time like this is his um home city so i
definitely understand it everything that
he knows and loves is here
part of me doesn't want to move either i
actually like the city it's just that
i'm not really progressing here at the
current company that i'm at
how long has your not compete for
for a year a year
have you sat down and dreamt about and
i'm i'm wandering back into ken's world
here have you dreamt about other ways to
tell stories of marginalized people that
that would allow you to
get some experience and some skills and
then in 366 days you
slide back into this role
yeah i thought about starting a small
small community newspaper for um and a
kind of lower income area of the city
here crystal how much money do you need
to make
not really that much it's not really
about the money well i understand i
understand
sanity sure you got to pay bills though
yeah we got some realities how much
money do you need to make you're not
married remember the so this is a
boyfriend he hadn't put a ring on it yet
how much money do you need to make
probably 50 000
okay i just want to be real honest with
you uh john's asking you the right
question there might be some other ways
to get to where you want to get to
besides moving from vegas to this job
however they've got to be realistic and
you're starting a community newspaper
you're not going to make 50 000. you're
going to lose 50 000. yeah that is a
that is not a reality and i don't want
to let you think that that's a reality
right
i want you to go back to the question
john yeah you didn't answer the question
you just talked about how you understood
his point of view because he's always
lived in vegas and everything he loves
is in vegas well it's about ready to not
be the case and if he loves you
uh i want to know john asked you a
really good question what part of that
vision that you so beautifully shared
with us does he not get excited about
he just doesn't see the need for me to
move he kind of believes that i should
be able to start my own thing here
whether it be like a website
tv station newspaper
et cetera i don't think he really has a
grasp of uh
yeah a reality
of journalism yeah
you know he needs a grasp of two things
number one uh how media like that
actually operates how long it takes to
get up and running how much money it
spends off and oh by the way you have to
take care of yourself you're not relying
on boyfriend i think this is a sit-down
conversation john where it's like this
is my vision now to john's point
i don't think you have to put all the
eggs in this basket of moving out of las
vegas however this move to this new
position
moves you up the ladder that was the
word i got most excited about ladders
what's great about ladders is as we move
up we have other options to move to
different places you could come back to
vegas but the reality is crystal you are
capped you have a lid on yourself
your words your reality it's a lid where
you are now and if you
don't
leave soon
to do what you know you're supposed to
do whether it's this position john where
she moves out of vegas
my concern is she's going to begin to
resent the boyfriend and i see that over
and over and over people a they don't
have the
the why conversation they don't get to
why it becomes a job i want this title
and that's not a reason to move it never
but when you're that wired into who you
are and your mission on earth
then that's a sit down conversation
because five years from now 10 years
from now
that's when the the the fires of
resentment will burn through that
relationship and it's hard to maintain
when you have a mission in life i'm
gonna tell you this right now i wouldn't
marry anybody who wasn't on board with
what i believe god created me to do
sorry hey don't move more ramsay show
coming right up
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
your money
let's go to jim in st louis hi jim
welcome to the ramsey show what's up
hey dave long time listener first time
caller uh sure appreciate everything
that you do for people well thank you
especially me and my family i am
me and my wife are 58
and i am i've been in the oil and gas
industry for 34 years
and just going through getting a
severance package
that will pay me to the end of the year
and my question is i've talked to my
local financial advisor
and uh to bridge the gap to get to 59
and a half
so i can start drawing
my uh
2.3 million that i've saved because of
you way to go i didn't give you any of
it you did it
good job dude
it was you it was you um
so uh
i just wanted to uh we we've got a
paid off house worth about 340
and don't know anything to anybody
and
look at your main question
my main question is to get through this
i i've just been in this industry that
has been 24 7
and i'm just drained and uh
to take a break and and
and get through this next uh
16 months that i need to get to to uh to
reach that
that goal or the that milestone of 59
and a half what'd you do on the rigs
uh actually i i'm actually in more of a
retail oil and gas
i was a general manager
and
so that's that's where just the
corporate life has changed so much and i
and and i haven't and uh
it just was time to separate so i got
you i got no issue with that but you've
got all these years of experience can
you not contract and do something for 40
hours a week for 16 months
well i've got i've got a in order to get
the severance i've got
a two-year non-compete that pretty much
limits how much is your severance
uh it is four months and how much is
that
uh
35 000.
i wasn't very generous
okay
so
you gave up two years for
35 grand
pretty much yeah
i've got about
25 grand in roth that i can pull from
without a penalty
and
um
i had always
talked about or thought about doing some
real property
and uh
just never really got pulled the trigger
and
so i've got
some advice to to if i need to
to use like our home equity
to get by to the 59 and a half and then
once i get to there
you know that whatever we
we have to use from that you know that
made me just throw up a little didn't
you
yeah i didn't make me too but i just i
was just the best i don't know who's
giving you that advice so i'd run from
them whoever they are they're an idiot
you're the guy with you're the guy with
over a three million dollar net worth
not the idiot telling you to go get a
home equity loan
okay oh my god why don't you just get
something to do and earn a little bit of
income for a little bit
even if it's not even if it's not in
your field
i don't want you to go work at walmart
as a greeter that's not what i'm talking
about you're worth three million dollars
but but um
you know i mean it seems to me that
you've got a substantial amount of
skills that you could be a consultant to
someone in something
for a short period of time here and be a
very big help to them and maybe make 50
or 100 grand and just eat on that a
little bit and put your 25 with it and
work it through because you don't have a
dime liquid except your emergency fund
is that right right i've got about 30
in in the
emergency fund and then i've got
25 and then you got this 35 severance
coming
correct yeah and so you got about 50
grand to work with and so you need
another 50 60 grand to get through the
six months right
or 16 months 16 months
yeah i mean your wife work outside the
home
yes she does what does she make
she makes uh 75. why can't y'all eat on
that man
yeah i mean that's that's why i'm saying
i'm not i'm i'm
i'm just really the conservative guy
and i just wanted to make sure that if i
don't do anything that i that we're
still okay obviously
we well you can make it it's going to be
tight and it's going to be a reduction
in lifestyle because you're used to
making bank
plus her 75. and now you got 35 and 20
plus her 75 plus whatever you can
scratch around and get as a consulting
gig until one of you hits 59 and a half
and you could begin a drawdown
but but i'm not going to tell you to go
borrow on your home equity loan dude
dance with a girl that brought you here
i'm with you
i'm with you i i
we put two girls through college they
made it out of college debt free and
we're just so proud of that and them and
uh
i'm proud of you man you're a freaking
hero
and last thing i want to see some hero
go get a home equity loan so i'll fight
you know but i and i i think what's
happening is too you're a little bit um
scarcely mindseted
no um you're so tired
um
i just hear emotional exhaustion
do i am i hearing that right
yes sir and so when i tell you hey just
go do some consulting you're like i
don't feel like getting out of bed
shut up man i finally got out of there
don't make me do that
[Laughter]
that's kind of what i'm hearing in your
spirit
and i think this is still fresh enough
so i'm gonna i'm gonna propose to you
that 90 days from now your emotions
probably will have healed a lot
and you'll be the other side of this
ptsd feeling and um
and i think you're the kind of person
that'll be a little bit bored at that 90
or 120 day mark
but right now you're still just kind of
walking wounded you got you're kind of
zombied
yeah am i wrong
no you're right and uh
and do you want just permission
do you just want permission when you
called
was one of your main points do you just
want permission to be able to stay home
with the severance with your wife
working and that's okay like is that is
that one was that one of your basis of
your questions
um
yeah i'd say that was half of it
probably yeah if you want to and you all
can do that i'm okay with that yeah
i'm not okay with the home equity loan
and i'm really not okay with the [ __ ]
that told you to do that
so probably just called your best friend
a [ __ ] but i don't really care
no i i have uh everybody that knows me
like my middle name is dave
not not for real but that's how it could
be because uh i if i wouldn't for you
listen i'm not the hero in this story i
just talked about it on the radio you
went and did it
yeah but it wouldn't happen probably if
it wouldn't come to your encouragement
and everything and i could imagine how i
would feel if it wasn't for that well
you're in great shape you deserve to
take a lap you deserve to take a uh some
time in this with your feet in the sand
somewhere
and um
uh you know and just enjoy the ride and
certainly with 59 and a half i want you
to cash out about a hundred grand and
just go do something fun uh you you've
done a wonderful job building wealth
you're a true baby steps millionaire you
did everything we teach true everyday
millionaire
and um you know multi-millionaire uh and
you just ran out of steam
uh
about 16 months early that's all it was
and that's okay that's all right you
still are going to be fine
so yeah if you want to live on the
income that you have and the income as
rachel said you want permission live on
your wife's income and the 35 000 and
the 20 000 until the 59 and a half mark
hits i'm happy for you to do that if you
all can do that and you want to write
that out as your budget go do it um i
also think you probably could add
another 50 or 100 grand easy to the top
line of this thing uh working 20 25
hours a week consulting for someone
somewhere that wasn't a violation of
your non-compete
because you you've just done
big stuff for too long to not have the
ability to lend yourself to something if
you want to
but right now today you can't hear that
i can and i'm okay with that i've been
right where you are i've been so tired i
can't breathe
your lungs hurt you just look you know
it's just i get it
so you're doing good work man and you
you did it touchdown take a victory lap
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage evan and jessica are
here hey guys congratulations how much
did you pay off we got a 136
377. wow all right how long did this
take
three years
all right nice cool and your range of
income during that time we started at 36
000 and we ended up at 120. goodness
gracious what do you guys do for a
living
i'm a project manager at a brand and
software development company cool
military awesome thank you for your
service hey thanks for your support very
nice very nice which branch uh army all
right good what was the 136 thousand
dollars in debt it was a lot
[Laughter]
we had copious amounts of student loans
we had vehicles
we had wedding rings a mattress yeah
that was a thing you borrowed everything
oh we did
you're like normal
some may say that yeah
fun where do you guys live
so we're originally from kansas city uh
metro area but stationed up at uh fort
knox oh yeah
how long have you been married
five years five years okay so you went
two years into marriage just kind of
doing everything
and then what happened three years ago
that he thought oh this is not working
so um
my aunt and uncle on my side they
were telling us their story about how
their they just got out of debt at our
grandmother's easter dinner
and so on the drive home we were like
well okay we're we're going into it
let's look at some podcasts and i
actually
i did a financial piece university about
uh three years prior mm-hmm it didn't
take sorry okay so
i'm a repeater yeah it's fine um and so
on our drive home we're like i think we
can do this i think we can do this and
we just dug in and we we just went for
it um we were like we need to get that
free um before we started family that
was our main goal oh um and uh so we we
actually did that because uh
we have a baby on the way so number
one's on the way
so
congratulations thank you thank you so
um we shared that news with uh her
brother and uh sister-in-law and they
actually paid off their debt the next
day oh wow they had enough to just throw
it all on there i'm all in boom we can
do that
but yeah we just we went gazelle intense
we just went for it wow wow okay so
you're newlyweds without kids mm-hmm so
the podcast gets it all started and is
that what you do you just listen to the
podcast over and over yeah we really did
and i attended uh we started a class
together for fpu but then we deployed
okay and then i did another class with a
friend of mine to get her started and
then we've recently led a class so
really just doing the classes but also
the podcast almost every day uh
kept us going and the debt free screams
helped us keep going too and and now
you're helping someone else keep going
yeah we're trying to get you well done
so proud of you guys thank you how does
it feel to be free
it feels amazing um our biggest push was
just changing our legacies uh both of us
come from families that didn't weren't
really responsible with money lost homes
went bankrupt and that was our biggest
motivator was we didn't want that for
our children
um so yeah it's it's a huge relief to go
into a new family like this yeah that's
cool that's cool a whole new imprint
yeah whole new family tree we're trying
to generational wealth that's fine
that's that's how it begins somebody's
got to start it might as well be you
right there you go i like it i like it
good for you guys well you tell people
now that you're coordinating a class you
paid off 136 000 in three years what do
you tell them the key is
uh communication and also organization
um because once you just have that first
conversation together because we were
both so
do we talk about finances how do we talk
about it but then we were able to bring
you in as like a third party to get mad
at if we needed to as far as decision
making went yeah
i knew i had it
dave was a customer during our hospital
yeah sometimes
yeah absolutely he's papa dave it really
got us just on the same page and then
from there like he said we were gazelle
intense and it really just helped us get
aligned
absolutely i was i was the free spirit i
didn't want to talk about it
at all so
but you engaged you
which is huge because that's a big part
of this whole journey it's very i mean
we rarely see married people up there
with just one of them right absolutely
they're both on it together and so both
of you guys being engaged what would you
encourage a couple out there maybe a guy
is listening right now because his wife
made him listen to this podcast and he's
like i don't know i don't want to do
this
what would you say to him you just gotta
ignore that side of your brain
and and just start get out of your
comfort zone try something new
engage with your spouse about money
because it is
crucial in a marriage to be on the same
page and uh it's no longer your finances
her finances her thing your thing no
it's it's it's together so from this
point on i mean you guys gotta be on
that same sheet of music and for the
encouragement of that in your marriage
would you say your marriage is an even a
better place today because of that
absolutely yeah yeah yeah
absolutely yeah and now it's the wedding
gift that we give all the time as you're
wow thank you thank you very much i
appreciate that no thank you it makes
shopping
really easy
and and with him preaching that sermon
at that and that with those pipes i
think we'll just take a break next
second let him let him
i think he's got the principles media
voice is phenomenal
[Laughter]
very well done you guys
what was the hardest part
ooh um
i think when you would deploy just
staying in communication
um and payment fluctuates too with my
job and his job that those moments where
you're not together anymore just staying
in line and staying on top of it i think
was probably the more difficult moments
we had absolutely yeah very very hard
yeah wow way to go well we've got a copy
of the legacy journey for you you're on
your way to being baby steps
millionaires i love it thanks and that's
the next chapter in your story because
that's your whole thing you're going to
change your legacy and so legacy journey
is a perfect book to give you guys and
also give you another copy of the total
money makeover help you with shopping
and you can give that away and pay it
pay it forward and advise someone else
if there's a guy on the radio that
anytime you need to be mad at somebody
he's your guy
he's your guy he can handle it i like
that that's fun very good very good
stuff
all right evan and jessica we're so
proud of you guys very very very well
done congratulations
a hundred and thirty six thousand
dollars paid off in three years making
36 to 120 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
two one
[Applause]
what a great couple i love it it's the
dinks dual income no kids and that's
maybe on the way did it now now baby
maybe on the way baby baby is here here
we go this is how it's done that's fun
and uh you know incomes are going up and
and
isn't it weird though the process i
never get over the process that
all of us go through in our brain
when we make the decision what exactly
what what evan said
uh you have to push yourself outside
your comfort zone you have to engage in
activities that you've never engaged in
if you want results you've never gotten
yep that's right if you keep doing the
same thing over and over again expect a
different result it's the definition of
insanity and that feels like the comfort
zone but it's also where things go to
die yeah well and to have hope that what
you're changing to is better
than your present right so like you know
it works like no one's stood on the
stage and screened i'm debt-free and
they're like i don't know i just don't
like it like i think we're gonna go get
a car loan you know i mean like you
don't feel that there's a level lifted
off like it works that's what happens
and so
when you do engage how does it feel oh
it's awful i'm going to get right back
as soon as i get out of here i don't
like it i think as soon as i get out of
here i'm going to the car i don't like
it
it's so great but like
change though is hard you know you
haven't said it but i'm like yeah the
friction you know even um with my kids i
switched their car seats a few weeks ago
on accident and my three or my
four-year-old now would not get in her
car seat because in the other side of
the car
and i thought even a four-year-old
doesn't like change right like it's
uncomfortable people it is but the
moment you say you know what i'm gonna
force myself to be uncomfortable for a
little bit because what i'm changing to
is better than my present it's worth it
so everybody go home
change car seats
right now change it up
your kids your kids won't be happy
that's not what we're talking about
changing metaphors change is hard though
it's a great metaphor i like i like the
i like the teaching it's very good
because it's mike your grandkids of
course i like anything with my great
kids this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
number one best-selling author and new
york times best-selling author of her
latest book know yourself know your
money you know we're talking about in
that last debt free screen being on the
same page with your spouse the know
yourself money assessment
is thirty dollars for a couple twenty
dollars for an individual it's great for
couples to get on the same page it takes
about 15 minutes and it delivers you
with 30 pages of personalized results
showing your money profile and beliefs
your money classrooms meaning how you
grew up your money tendencies your fears
your motivations your attitudes your
actions it's not all what you're doing
wrong it's what you do right and what
you do wrong and just your way of
looking at things and it gives you a
communication tool to work with your
spouse the know yourself
money assessment one of the more popular
things in the store at
ramseysolutions.com
how many of you guys are stressed out or
hurting because your retirement savings
is scaring you with all this stuff going
on in the world
well you need to have someone in your
corner
to help you with this
you gotta have someone to walk with you
talk with you teach you do you really
have something to be concerned about or
are you just in freak out mode because
sometimes we all got a little drama
queen inside of us right
and me too
so what we recommend is you have a smart
vester pro in your corner we're not in
the investment business but we have
vetted and
done detailed research on people who do
investing out there do investing advice
for you investment brokers and these are
people with the heart of a teacher and
they agree with us on what we teach so
you're going to get the similar and same
advice so click smart vester at ramsey
solutions dot com or hit ramsay
solutions.com smartvestor either one and
um you can find a list of the smart
investor pros in your
area and one of them will sit down with
you and help you with your stuff
all right find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more they give us our
question of the day always use the promo
code ramsey to get the best possible
deal today's question comes from whitney
in missouri
i'm a saver and my husband is a spender
we set up a budget when we got married
and included an allowance for each of us
to help monitor our spending he has been
reluctant and not a good follower of our
budget is having this allowance
something that you suggest if so how
much should we allot for our personal
spending and how do i fix
the issue of my husband going over the
set amount
oh man um
well a couple things whitney that stood
out in your question
we set a budget when we got married so
it's not like we said it last month so
i'm curious how long the discussion has
been how long you guys have been married
because the incur my encouragement would
be that you guys talk about it every
month
and
the allowance is it a good idea yeah the
word allowance is always weird for me
but i always say to have a personal line
item in your budget so for our family
for instance there's a rachel line item
there's a winston line item actually our
kids even have their own line items now
so i just know okay when we're spending
it like this is this is where it's
coming out of
um
and that amount is going to depend on
your income and where you guys are in
the baby steps so
uh
how do i fix basically how do i fix my
husband well when you don't fix your
husband i'm sorry that doesn't it's not
how it works
uh you do have to
talk to him not preach at him but
come at these conversations in a way
that you can express what is going on in
you
whether it's frustration whether you're
scared whether you don't know what to do
whether it's you long for him to be more
involved i mean expressing these needs
in a way that is not
um
putting him down right like i feel like
some
savers
which contend can be more of the nerds
in the relationship
can get very legalistic and it's this
way this way this way here's how much
money you have and when you do that to
your husband like the dynamic changes it
kind of goes from this like
marriage to
a mom to her son or something like it
gets weird so
um yeah like your language is that way
not yours rachel the person in
giving him an allowance yeah whitney
this sounds like you're his mother yeah
you were to this not as not his wife
and so like he won't stick to his
allowance it's like oh my god what is
wrong so here's the thing you need to
sit down again and the two of you need
to decide what you want your future to
look like and what you're willing to do
to get to that future
instead of he needs to stick to his
allowance
he's a dadgum grown man he should stick
to his own allowance
because he wants to hit the goals that
he's agreed to
square your shoulders bubba man up here
okay that's not your mama this is your
wife and you're supposed to be part of
this team pulling the harness and so you
guys need to look out there in the
future together hold hands and go
there's where we want to go and here's
the price we're going to pay to get to
where we want to go and we both want to
get there so we're both going to pay
that price and that includes i'm going
to limit my personal spending to this
and you're going to limit your personal
spending to that and that's what we're
in agreement to not i'm going to be
you know schooling you up every time you
misbehave so the bottom line is is i i
don't think we did a budget i think you
did a budget and told him what it was
that's what it sounds like yeah yeah
and so i think he needs to get his butt
in gear and emotionally plug into
co-leading this household
this is your wife's son it's not your
mama
and so man up
and take take that take your share of
the responsibility and lady quit babying
him he's not your little boy
and that's the kind of thing that we're
talking about here now that's language
that people don't like in today's world
well go listen to another radio show
then because that's the way this really
this crap really works i've done this
for 30 years
and so um
you know you guys can sit down there
together love each other love your
future
say gosh i'll do anything in the world
for you except stick to my allowance see
that that's the problem is the word
means that you allowed him to have a
certain amount of money and he didn't
stick to it right well ain't your job to
allow him
it's our job to decide what we are going
to do yep that's the point that's the
way this stuff the the language in this
reveals it all yes and what happens so
many times in marriage when it comes to
money is the spouse becomes the enemy
right it's like well he he or she won't
and yeah there's issues there and in a
tactical way that if they are just going
and spending tons of money you're trying
to get i get that
but instead of seeing your spouse as the
enemy look at the things that are not
being done or look at the debt like like
have things out there that are the issue
and you guys lock arms
together and look at the problem your
spouse isn't the problem
um
yeah and you know you do a great job of
teaching about this on the budgeting
stuff in financial peace university this
idea that
and i forget the you do better with the
language than i do because i'm just kind
of mean about it but
this this idea that that um
both of you have to step up
and this i there's a lot of people had
model had parents modeling for you and
you took that model and it was a bad
model
and they they mean to they weren't they
weren't bad people but um you know dad
just worked and he never looked at the
money and mama handled all the details
and mama paid the bills and so dad was
emotionally when it came to the
operation of the household yeah
subservient to his wife yeah or mom is
like well i don't know my husband takes
care of me i don't know what i'm and
she's over here and she's deficit and is
emotionally not plugged in and it's not
being a fully developed grown-up
in the situation both of you have to be
fully developed emotional mature
grown-ups
pulling together for the same goal when
we see that we see people change their
lives absolutely that's that's it that's
well said because both extremes
are not good you're not going to get it
on both extremes but this is not a
mansplaining thing no and it's not a
momsplaining thing no it's not trashing
your parents thing it's none of that
there's no there's no victim or
entitlement stuff in here it's simply
you are not listen i'm not good with
money i just i let my wife handle and
she's so much smarter than me you're not
doing her a favor
you're not a blessing to her and you
even though you paid her a big
compliment she wishes she didn't have
all the weight of the decision-making on
her shoulders
well my husband's really good with this
stuff his name is dave ramsey he knows
he tells everybody in america how to
handle money so i don't have to handle
money those words never left sharon
ramsey's mouth
she wants her vote to count she wants
her voice to be heard and and not in a
nagging way no but she is not
just take care of me i'm a little
southern belle and you just take it
she's not that woman yeah and because
she's like a full-grown mature woman you
know i mean oh my gosh this is what
we're talking about here both of you
step into this thing and then you'll go
win
well said this is the ramsay show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america rachel cruz ramsey
personality new york times best-selling
author and my daughter
is my co-host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five rachel's latest
book know yourself know your money new
york times best seller is all about how
you discover why
you handle the money the way you do and
then what to do about it
see we've talked for 30 years around
here what to do now rachel's talking to
you about why you do some of the things
you do that are good
and some of them that you do that are
bad right yeah that's right but
understanding your motivations when it
comes to money
really explains your habits why you make
the decisions you make
all of that so it unpacks everything
from childhood
to tendencies to dreams to fears all of
it and it's
it's so it's so fascinating i love this
stuff i mean i love anything
self-discovery because i just think
we're complex people and you can kind of
get to the root of things you're like
that's why i do what i do you know and
it's it's i think it's always
fascinating so when you can grow and
learn from the roots it will help you in
all the things obviously that we've
you've taught for 30 years of the how-to
but a lot of this stuff you've i mean
you've seen it like this book wasn't
a shock to you or surprised well no but
you took you took like you know i said
nerd or free spirit spender or saver
yeah and that's two of the constructs in
the entire book um but there's something
about um it's like a ramsey pastime
family thing that we really do enjoy
trying to figure out what makes people
tick mm-hmm why so-and-so is doing what
they're doing and how they do that and
why and then
and really so that's why we like
assessments that's why we like you know
disc and enneagram and strength finders
and the disc in fifth grade i couldn't
even read half the words i was like i
don't know
we're packing and we're moving we found
daniel's
your little brothers when he was 12.
disc profile disc profile what is it
he lied
he laughed about it no he laughed about
it because he said i didn't know what it
was and he said so i just answered all
the questions any old way and it's like
a straight line it's like he's nothing
oh funny and so now
we do know what he is now he's a very
high d very high d.i yeah a lot like his
dad so but um
that's so
different on the enneagram though way
different on the enneagram but yeah yeah
so we've got these great assessments the
know yourself money assessment that
rachel and our incredible research team
have put together
it's thirty dollars for a couple twenty
dollars for an individual what it does
is it takes 15 minutes to take it it's
and it spits out 30 pages of
personalized results and it talks about
your money classrooms talk about the
money classrooms for a minute because i
think that's insightful uh once you kind
of know where you came from it helps you
know how to get where you're going
yeah absolutely well there's two ways
money was communicated in your home
growing up verbally what was said and
then emotionally what it was felt in the
home right the environment and so it
creates kind of this quadrant
and so that first money classroom is the
anxious money classroom and this is if
your home was verbally closed so money
was not talked about but emotionally
stressed so if you grew up in this
household it was
the feeling like at the end of the month
you just felt tension around you didn't
you know you didn't really know but oh
you just felt it in the air didn't dare
bring it up no classroom two is the
unstable money classroom this is where
it's verbally open it is talked about
but it's emotionally stressed so
conflict fighting you heard your parents
have the same money fight possibly over
and over again uh it was there and then
classroom three is the unaware money
classroom and this is where it's
verbally closed it's not talked about
but it's emotionally calm
so i always say with this classroom if
you grew up you probably were one of the
ones that left home at like 1821 and you
thought i know nothing about money and
oh it's oh it is a big deal okay i gotta
figure this out because no one talked
about it and it just didn't seem like a
big deal it's just like that's just what
it is and then classroom four is
probably the healthiest it is the
healthiest money classroom and that's
where it's verbally open and emotionally
calm
so money is talked about it's not taboo
you are engaged in conversations from
tactical things like what a 401k is to
more you know emotional things like um
generosity and contentment and the value
money plays in our life right like that
was just talked about but it was also
calm because there was a plan probably
around money there was a level of yep we
know what we're doing
you could have cooperation collaboration
between the parents yeah yeah i mean and
and in that classroom you don't have to
have a million dollars right you can you
can you you don't have to be wealthy in
that classroom by any means either so so
just kind of knowing what i found in all
the research when i was writing about
this is
people either really mirrored what they
knew growing up so
if we didn't talk about money i just
won't talk about money either like i'll
just shut it down or people did the
exact opposite so i've heard many people
say yeah my parents fought all the time
about money so it's not worth it it's
not worth engaging in conversation it's
not worth the fight we'll just figure it
out and i don't want to go there um or
my parents never talk to us about money
and you hear someone say so now i'm like
constantly on my kids to be like you
have to learn this stuff so it's just
interesting to see people
again you either just mirror what you
know without realizing it
or people just did the exact opposite
but i think that it shapes you
and just that's the foundation that's
laid that i mean any any therapist would
say your household growing up was your
classroom to life it's where you learned
life's lessons and same with money and
so
this is where you learned it and you got
to figure out what lessons you want to
take with you into adulthood what
lessons you wish you could probably
unlearn
all of it but it's it's interesting to
kind of go back there and say okay this
is it and
as well add this
if you have siblings
ask your siblings what kind of classroom
they felt like they grew up in because
even depending on your personality you
could have a
a perspective of one classroom and your
sibling has another of how they
saw things or or understood things so
yeah you were born the year we filed
bankruptcy so when ours was an unstable
yeah
freaked out
losing everything classroom you were too
small to to know it your sister was a
toddler
probably also too small but might have
you know distant memories somewhere deep
down in her psyche of that but
you know so our family went through a
shift yes which happens we went through
from you know being a meltdown
disastrous mess
me and your mom up to by the time you
were old enough to know
it was pretty calm and organized and
methodical because we were already doing
this stuff and teaching this stuff
absolutely yep for sure for sure and so
like you know you you were doing the
writing for this and you said well i
grew up in a very calm and stable and
we're like yeah you just weren't old
enough to remember when it wasn't yeah
that's all i know i had the manuscript
we had dinner and i was like here's what
i'm writing about and i feel like you
know it was this like it was classroom
four for the most part and you're like
yeah cause you're too young to remember
classroom two
unstable it was crazy that's crazy when
we were nuts
oh yeah they can still get there
we can get there we just don't live
there
we can drive by now and say hi
but that's all
oh my gosh yeah this stuff is so
valuable though to know where you come
from and you get and then you look at
your spouse and you go oh
you have a little bit of empathy for
them
when you know kind of okay that's where
you came from oh you're
more of an abundance versus scarcity and
i'm kind of scarcity oh you're more
saver i'm more spender oh
you like to spend on experiences you
like to spend on things yeah it's
winston as biggest rub yup yup i want to
go to disney rachel the kids aren't
listening 100
would spend 100 of our money on
experiences i just take vacations all
day long
and what i want to spend on disney what
sounds like eating out has nothing to do
with the food
it's the entertainment appetite it's the
entertainment
[Music]
when you ask once about rachel he says
rachel's a fun girl he said you make me
more fun he just said that to me
yesterday
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality
number one best-selling author new york
times bestselling author of her last and
latest book not our last book but our
latest book
know yourself know your money my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five shelley's in
destin florida hi shelly how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i just need some advice me and my
husband have been paying off her debt
we're down to one last credit card um it
totals out to be 10
596.90
and um we're thinking about borrowing it
from the 401k we don't have much in
there we have around 21 000 in our 401k
and we're just trying to make the best
choice
uh the credit cards at a 24 interest
so i just need some advice how much was
the total of the credit card did you say
ten thousand
ten thousand five hundred ninety six
dollars okay ninety cents yeah
okay
what's your household income
51
okay
all right how long you've been listening
to this show
um i've heard about you guys
through church members
and
i just actually signed up for your
your classes
and your apps that you'll have yes i
just did that um
i'm just really excited to get
out of debt because i mean we do cash
advances and all kinds of things and we
pay off probably over a hundred thousand
wow i'm dead yeah
you're tired you're tired of the fear
and the chaos aren't you
yes i am and just living from paycheck
to paycheck
you know not knowing you know what's
gonna come next
my husband oh he's so on board with
getting out of debt um
it stresses him out a lot you know uh
just being all that responsibility on
him
and so um and plus i want him to be able
to retire at us at a nice age to enjoy
you know everything and to line our
lives up you know biblically with the
bible that's the most important thing so
you guys are sweet people
you're sweet well thank you um
well i'm glad that you're plugged into
ramsey plus and into financial peace
university we'll walk you through
rachel and i are two of the main
teachers in the in those videos that
you're going to go through
and we're going to show you how to get
on a budget which is going to help you
get out of the payday advanced stuff
because that comes from
not planning well when you start doing
your budget you're going to hear us say
it again on the videos but you'll feel
like you've got a raise
because being out of control makes you
it makes you
make wrong decisions i've been there too
i know how it feels i've done it too
okay
um
and here's the thing you're gonna be
able to pay off the credit card
so
if
fast
follow the stuff that we teach in detail
and both you and your husband are doing
it that the interest rate's not going to
matter much
okay because you're going to pay it off
in under a year
okay probably under six months because
you're not going to do anything so pay
off this credit card we're going to
teach you to get so focused on it
because you're sick of it and the great
news about where you are the way you're
speaking about this you're doing it with
such an open hand
and um it's almost kind of tender just
listening to you that you are you're at
the perfect place you're like just teach
me just show me how i'm just sick of it
i'll do anything and that's what i keep
hearing from you and so what that tells
me having done this for 30 years is
you're going to have great success in
the next 12 months it's going to blow
your mind where you are by next summer
don't you think rachel yeah well i was
going to say shelly i mean
from how you guys have been living to
what you're about to engage in and
actually get a plan and we said this in
an earlier segment you know but the
there'll be changes you'll do stuff
that's different than you've ever done
before and it's gonna first feel
uncomfortable
but push through that because
immediately when you start to live on a
budget and it works you know you are in
control of your money versus your money
controlling you
you have a plan you and your husband are
on the same page you're working toward
the same goal i mean all of that is so
cohesive when it works
and it's an amazing thing like you will
never experience the level of control
that you're about to have and and yep
and he's exactly right i'm like yeah
there's no need to take out a 401k loan
at all don't do it don't do that um when
you guys start to do the math and you
start to see okay here's where our money
can go
you're gonna you're gonna pay it off
you're gonna be able to do this yeah
interest rate matters if you're gonna
keep the debt around for five years
but when you're gonna keep it around for
six months or seven months or whatever
you end up with is ten thousand dollars
it's not gonna it's not gonna matter
much the second thing is you never
borrow in any circumstance for all you
listeners out there on a 401k here's why
you unplug
in her case half of your 401k 10 000 of
his 20 000 that's invested is now
unplugged from good investments making
10 or 12 percent in good mutual funds
and instead you pay yourself back 5
or 6 or 7 or however it's set up it's
one of those three numbers
and um
so you you're trading off for a bad a
bad rate of return so it is costing you
more than it appears to be costing you
the second thing is when you leave your
company and you will leave your company
you will die
you will get a better job or you will
get fired one of the three ways you will
leave your company when you leave your
company not if
your 401k loan
is considered by the irs in early
withdrawal and you have 60 days to
completely repay it oh by the way you
just don't have a job anymore
but you have 60 days to repay the loan
or it's considered an early withdrawal
and you're taxed and penalized on it
so it's a disaster looking for a place
to happen so never
borrow on a 401k
now that's
that's a sidebar really because shelly
your story is so much bigger than just
the ten thousand dollars because you're
going to such really really really good
places i'm so proud of you all right
dylan is with us in springfield mass hey
dylan what's up
hey how's it going dave better than i
deserve how can we help sir
uh well i'm 25 i make about 80 grand a
year uh i got 420 bucks a month in
expenses i'm currently debt free minus
my 401k loan that you're just talking
about um i'm currently living with my
grandmother right now
i got 22 000 in savings and i want to
buy a house but like i'm not real sure
where to go from here or what to do with
the market the way it is and all the
houses around me are pretty expensive so
i'm just not super sure what to do cool
yeah it's a great question how much is
your 401k loan
uh i think there's about eight left on
it okay write a check today and pay it
okay
and now we've got not 22 but now we have
14.
but you make 80 and you got no bills
because you live with your grandmother
right so you pile up money pretty fast
can't you
right minus the expenses because i kind
of take care of her too with you know
groceries and everything else but yeah
well what i would encourage you dylan is
to figure out what your expenses are per
month
and then get an emergency fund of three
to six months worth of that have that
just cash in the bank which again that
18 it's gonna it's going to help you
with the 14.
um that's left in your savings will be a
good jump start if not completed
depending on again what your expenses
are um and then from there is what we
call baby step 3b
and that is where you're going to save
up for your down payment on your home
and that's you want to save up at least
10 to 20 percent
and then the formula we always use is
that your take home your your payment is
no more than 25 of your take-home pay on
a 15-year fixed rates
now that's to say if you want to buy a
home and i don't know your situation uh
are you single
yeah yeah is buying a home something you
want to do or you do you want to rent
for a little bit do you want to stay
with your grandmother like what are you
what do you want to do
i'd like to buy a house okay i had one
already i sold a year ago gotcha
they built houses right on top of mine
so i sold mine but yep i do
want a house yeah yeah yeah so yeah when
you get to that point that you have that
down payment saved up
um then i think it's then it's a great
time i mean you're gonna you're in a
good position obviously you're gonna be
completely debt free by this afternoon
because you're gonna write a check and
get that taken care of
uh and you have some good savings you
can save up a little bit more but that
um that down payment savings will be
your next your next step
good work brother good work the question
you gotta ask it sounds like more than
anything is just how long do you need to
be there and want to be there
to uh take care of your grandmother in
this situation and um you know
it's working for now
uh is that a three-year plan a
three-month plan five year plan and then
that'll help you answer when you're
ready to buy but yeah get out of debt
build your emergency fund and save your
down payment like rachel laid out that's
exactly what we teach
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
joshua and anna are with us hey guys how
are you hi
well i'm water now that we see you good
to have you
thank you for having us well we're
honored to have you thank you for being
here and where do you guys live new
jersey in jersey and all the way to
nashville to do a debt-free scream
that's right how much did you pay off 70
437 in 10 months
and your range of income during that
time uh it started at 102 and it has
ended now in 202.
all right what do you guys do for a
living i am an icu nurse
and i'm an audio tech all right wow you
guys are killing it way to go
very good what kind of debt was this 70
000
oh my gosh it was it was a car payment
it was a student loan debt and it was
credit cards
30 000 and student loans nine thousand
in cards and the rest um was the car so
you guys were just normal yeah we were
yeah
so i mean it not not going well at all
but kind of felt like normal yeah it's
just the way everybody is right normal
just a little too long though
i hear you so uh what happened a year
ago they got you guys fired up and doing
this ramsey stuff this started um in
january well we've been together since i
was 17 and he was
um actually longer than that we were
together since high school so we had our
oldest daughter when we were really
young and um all we've known is work and
struggle and that
for
20 years
um
it's going to be 13 years since we've
been married this september so
uh back in 2019 in january we went to a
marriage conference in kingsway church
in cherry hill and they had a clinic
about finances and anita and steve jenka
if you guys are watching they were the
ones that touch base on the finances and
talked about fpu
and that's when the light bulb went out
for us
i thought maybe it doesn't have to be
struggle all the time yes well
it went a little bit further we had some
savings
that exceeded the amount of debt but
they were savings you know trying to
accumulate you know for the for the kids
whatever and somehow just not being
reckless and just thinking that the
harder you work the you know just with
hard hard work hard work hard work well
we weren't budgeting we weren't paying
attention to our finances
and it was just work work work work work
work work chaotic
hectic lifestyle
um
and you feel like a rat in a wheel oh it
disappeared
it just disappeared the money
disappeared yeah oh yeah
yes you had a leak yeah it no it wasn't
material things it was just no big item
stuff will come up and it's like get
take a thousand here or whatever yeah
that's what it changes
wow and so then you've got all that
regret
which tastes really nasty on the back of
your tongue extremely we almost i mean i
lost it you know um it was towards the
end of 19.
september 2009 i lost it i said this is
this is it i'm done with the struggle
i'm just had it i'm not living like this
anymore no no i i said i like this guy
i'd rather go on my own i said i i told
my wife i said if i'm gonna struggle
i'll just move into a room you can have
everything i said but i i can't continue
i'm gonna i'm gonna drive myself into
the grave
um and it was just so then then you go
to the marriage conference in financial
peace university and you say i got to go
to that class and they started it in
september of 2019. oh
yes so we we heard about it january we
started the class september 2019 fpu and
um it was hard because every time we
watched those videos it would just be
like a slap in the face
like dave is calling me stupid again yes
and
it was hard on us because every time we
tried to sit down and have a budget
meeting it was fights because we could
not believe when we added up 70 000
we were like we're gonna be dead by the
time we get this paid off it's never
going to happen we were hopeless that's
the the right word and um and you know
when did that turn
when did they when did it turn from
hopeless to hopeful um after the life
group you know just having that sense of
community
and seeing people from all different
kinds of walk of life you know so the
other people in the financial peace
university yeah yeah there was there was
a doctor in there yeah it was you know
you don't feel so dumb because everybody
said no no not at all you know that's
when it like sank in okay well maybe we
can do this yeah okay and then covet hit
yep and you're a nurse yes i see you
nervous i see a nurse and it gets better
it gets better covet hit and i'm just as
i'm starting my 2020 season
um because i work for the union so it's
all theatrical
and mainstream production so live well
the first whiff was all the
pharmaceutical trade shows and
conferences were cancelled okay
that's not good then when live nation
did their release you know they they
canceled the whole
touring season yep that was like oh my
goodness and i'm like now this couldn't
get any you know we gained some momentum
from 2019 we got the rhythm down we got
you know so got the wheels were you
working all the time though so what
happened was when covet hit he lost his
job because there was no concerts no no
event and he was like i can't i can't
stay home like i have to go and find a
job and i said to him listen i'm an icu
nurse i can't escape this we have no
idea what's going on we have no idea how
you know what's happening what we know
is that it's bad so and we had just
actually gotten our sander insurance
life policy we had just gotten it
approved in january right before covert
hit so i told them the girls don't need
to lose to parents you know you stay
home you take care of the girls you help
them with homeschooling and you stay
safe and we i will go on our work
and he wasn't too happy about it but i'm
like i'm doing it i'm not gonna have you
out there risking your life for pennies
on the dollar you know compared to what
he was making before so just stay home
you got like triple time so i was
working six days a week 13 14 hour
shifts yeah your pay went through the
roof and so i was working my full-time
job uh
and then i went to travel nursing so i
was working three days a week around
home and i was working another three
days a week up north about an hour so
you might you made a couple of hundred
that year yeah yeah and so i was living
in a trailer outside of my house because
i was scared to get you know get them
sick and stuff it was a little rough in
the beginning but you know we saw we saw
our opportunity to be gazelle intense
and that's what i did and i just want to
thank you guys because you know
unknowingly you and rachel and all the
ramsey personalities and all the callers
were the ones that kept me going so on
my drives up north you know all my long
nights and my long mornings i would
listen to all the podcasts and that's
what would keep me going you know not
being able to see my family not be able
to be with them it was really hard on
them it was really hard on me but we
were just focused we were zeroed in on
being debt-free because we got tired of
being tired of being tired well you took
a really hard scary
yeah situation and the work you did
thank you for all the work throughout
this um this time
and you took it you said okay what can i
do how can i better my family in this in
this hard time and then you guys
together
made that decision and and it's amazing
and when you thought you guys are never
gonna be the same never
it's not only that but i mean that
hopeless chaotic we're stuck in a rut
will never get out you're never going to
think that way again the rest of your
life your brain has been stretched to a
different level you'll never you can't
go back to the same shape people think
we're crazy like oh you are you're
awesome at work they're like why are you
working so much it was a campaign that
like i work around with my budget
everywhere i go and i show it to all my
nurse friends i show it to everyone i
talk to my patients about it i'm very
very we're very passionate about it yeah
so last thing i'm worried about is what
you care whether you care about it
that's awesome
you are amazing this is such a great
story we've got a copy of the total
money makeover for you in the legacy
journey for you the legacy journey is
the next
chapter in your story because you guys
have completely changed your whole lives
yes
so impressed you're amazing
wow thank you guys man oh man we're so
so grateful you have no idea wow
wow i feel like you just came through a
war
man that's amazing wow all right joshua
and anna
leah and
melania melania ah beautiful name sorry
i was about to mess it up there and 70
000 paid off but boy oh boy oh boy in 10
months making 102-202
never be the same again this family
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream are you guys you guys ready yep
three
two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
thanks for joining us america
our scripture of the day jeremiah 32 17
o sovereign lord you have made the
heavens and the earth by your great
power and outstretched arm
nothing is too hard for you
arnold palmer said always make a total
effort
even when the odds are against you
now you hear us by the way talk about
term life insurance all the time guys
that's because term life insurance can
make all the difference financially for
your family
if god forbid something happens to you
you heard that last couple say
you know we're facing these really scary
unknowns with kovad you remember when we
all didn't know anything about covet
and most of us admitted it back then
um but uh man
that family went and got life insurance
didn't they that's what they said and
they had gotten it before covett all
started right
our term life calculator makes it easy
for you to find the right policy it
shows you how much coverage you'll need
and it takes less than five minutes to
get your numbers here's what to expect
first answer a few questions give us a
snapshot of your life
the free calculator will then tell you
how much coverage you need it's usually
about 10 to 12 times your annual income
and how long you need to keep the
insurance and then you'll be able to
compare rates and select the best policy
through xander our trusted partner they
shop over a dozen insurance carriers
help you find the best deal to get your
results text term life to 33 789 we'll
help you with the term life calculator
it's very easy
text term life two three three
seven
eight nine and you can make sure
that your family is taken care of
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five rachel cruz
ramsey personality best-selling author
and my daughter is my co-host today
josh is with us in chattanooga hi josh
what's up
i'm doing great how you doing dave
better than i deserve how can i help
well i've got i've always been an
employee and here recently my i've had a
youtube channel that has really taken
off
and i'm starting to get paid from that
and i'm not sure i have people telling
me i need like a you know business
license or llc where i can write off
these expenses but i'm not sure if i
really need that
wow good for you
what kind of money are you making off of
youtube
uh well like this week i made 900 off
youtube so it's i mean it's trending up
real fast but like this week i made 900
bucks so it's doing really well so if
that continues you might make 50 60
grand a year or more
yeah that's what i'm hoping what's your
channel about josh i'm just curious
i get old cars running i've been sitting
20 30 years the channel sleeper dude
okay yeah
very cool
you'd like it dave i think i would i'm a
bit of a gearhead i think i'm like
watching you what's it called again i'll
look it up
sleeper dude all one word i'll be
looking for your comments sleeper
dude as in as in take a nap sleep oh
it's the car's a sleeper car oh okay
yeah i got it oh okay i didn't touch on
that no i understand okay cool well we
just told 22 million people so hopefully
we'll get your youtube revs up
all right um yeah anyway
anyway um
for those of you that don't know the
more viewers you have on youtube once
you reach a certain point they will
actually start paying you because the
ads that they run on your youtube
video they make money on and they share
a little of it with you not much but a
little
and uh so he's if he's getting 900 a
week off of this he's got quite a good
viewership it's uh you don't get that
with 500 of your friends looking on it's
it's tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands to get to that point so very
cool we make a little money on youtube
too but uh here's the thing you you do
not need an llc unless you want one you
what you do want to do is open a
separate
business checking account
and uh put all of your youtube revenues
or any other money you make on this
endeavor if you bought a car and sold it
uh as a part of the business or
something like that you would put any
money you make into that account and you
the only thing you write out of that
account are business expenses
okay and so if you bought some video
equipment if you bought some tools to
work on the cars
anything like that you're doing that's
associated with the business that would
be a business expense needs to come out
of that account and so if you put all
the income of the business into that
account and the only thing you take out
of that account are business expenses by
definition what's left in there is your
profit
right okay revenue minus expenses is
profit now then if you take some of the
profit home
you'll pay taxes on it i'll come back to
that in a minute all right but if you
take that the information in your
checking account the income
and the expenses
and you sit down to do your taxes you
can do it as a sole proprietor on
schedule c or you can have a tax
preparer do it or you can
incorporate it into an llc if you want
to it's not necessary for you to write
it off though you can write it off as a
sole proprietor and not have to open up
something the only reason you really
need an llc is if you're afraid of being
sued for something
okay yeah i wouldn't be worried about
that really not not not yet you get a
big enough number on this some idiot
will figure out a way to sue you but um
yeah but but but in the meantime uh
right now 50 grand is not a big enough
target on your butt you don't have to
worry about it but you start cranking
off three or four hundred on this go
ahead and get an llc okay
is there like a percentage i should save
back for taxes exactly that's my next
that's my next speech
so um
when you take money out of this business
account
that we just opened josh's sleeper cars
or with sleeper dudes or whatever this
kind of thing right the sleeper dude
account when you take money out of it
and bring it home
i want you to set aside a fourth of that
into a separate savings account for
taxes okay because you're supposed to
pay quarterly estimates on your business
to the irs now the quarterly estimate is
a one-page form that shows the revenues
for the quarter the expenses for the
quarter there for the profit for the
quarter and then estimate your tax based
on that profit and you're supposed to
send them that amount of money which
will be about a fourth of this it'll be
very close
okay
all right right when you so when you
calculate that now the cool thing is
when you go to fill out your quarterly
estimates if you've set aside a fourth
of your profit
out of this account any money you take
out of this account so you pull a
thousand bucks out of this account you
write 250 over into the tax savings
account for your quarterlies and you
write 750 into your personal account to
spend buy groceries with
yeah okay
and that's that's the process so
set aside a fourth until you get to
making oh more than a hundred and
hundred and something then you'll have
to go a little more than a fourth but
for right now i think and that's profit
not gross so for right now i think a
fourth will be very very close for you
so really two big things one is a
separate checking account that gives you
your profit and then when you take money
out the separate savings account to pay
your taxes your withholding on yourself
is what you're doing does that make
sense to you
that makes sense
very cool congratulations man i'm proud
of you that's a neat thing it's fun when
you kind of stumble into something you
know and he's like oh wow i get to make
videos something i love
and i'm making 900 bucks a week it's fun
there's guys and gals doing stuff on
youtube that are making serious
money i mean our friend our friends
tyler and the gang the dude perfect guys
they are they've been killing it for
years
and
sharp sharp young men but i mean they're
the top five six youtube channels in the
world they're huge and so they're making
a lot more than 900 a week on that uh to
say the least like a lot of zeros but
and good because they're what they're
doing is good clean fun and it's
entertaining families love other kids
families the kids love it and it's just
an incredible youtube channel we had
them speak at uh our entree leadership
summit down in dallas the other day when
we were down there just great guys yep
yep great guys and so you know there's
this youtube thing is um
uh there there's some serious uh players
in it and just social media i'm like
people have large instagram accounts and
there may i mean like they it's well the
influencers is a different crowd yes
but the youtube crowd is is uh some of
those are influencer types too yeah but
some of them are actually content you
know they're actually have content
they're actually providing entertainment
or they're providing instruction on
something or whatever and it's going
beautifully and um you know our show of
course this show is broadcast every day
on youtube yep and so and it's got a
huge following thank you guys on thank
you to the the youtube people call
themselves the youtube crazies hello
thanks youtube crazies we appreciate you
being there
all right that puts us this hour of the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you